increases in glucocorticoids are
sufficient but not necessary to increase
cooperative burrowing in demaraland mole
rats
okay that that
is of some interest to some of us um
maybe not to many people uh
glucocorticoids being um
corticosteroid hormones that are
involved in things like reducing
inflammation and are understood to be
part of a generalized stress response
uh
cooperative burrowing in these mole rats
that are different from naked mole rats
but also do a lot of cooperative
behavior um these these authors went in
interested to look for this this
mechanism this hormonal mechanism to see
if it was causal in prompting this
behavior and that's a pretty standard
approach in um you know that you would
find in a journal like this hormones and
behavior like you know behavioral
endocrinology
animal behavior that's trying to get it
mechanism as opposed to sticking to
uh observations of the behavior
themselves itself
we'll tend to go and look and find yay
or nay like yes this
when when we increased or when
uh we saw that it was increasing
natively
when it increased we saw increases in
this behavior or we did not
what these authors do and they put it
right up front in the title which struck
me as
important for us to just flag
was that they found that yes in this
case
when increase when glucocorticoids
excuse me are increased
experimentally in these mole rats they
do find an increase in cooperative
burrowing but
while sufficient
while an increase in this hormone is
sufficient to prompt a change in
behavior it is not necessary to do so
and we usually in science talk about
things being necessary
but not sufficient and this here is
sufficient but not necessary which may
well be a much more common thing
and i thought that was that was worth
just spending a couple minutes on yeah
it absolutely is um i used to and i
don't recall but i suspect you used to
also
do a module on necessary and sufficient
and
uh in our teaching in our teaching right
and so you know there are things which
are
necessary and sufficient there are
things which are necessary but not
sufficient and there are things which
are sufficient but not necessary and
just simply having those categories so
that you this is like one of the basic
building blocks of understanding a
complex system
and i so
an egg
is necessary but not sufficient
uh to produce a uh human embryo
right for instance so i want to point to
one of the reasons that this is such a
useful rubric to to walk into complex
systems with and it has to do actually
with you know let's talk for a second
about what a hormone is right a hormone
is a chemical message that is released
in one part of the body that has effects
remotely right so it functions
mechanistically very much like a
neurotransmitter but a neurotransmitter
is uh crossing a very tiny distance in a
synapse for example whereas a hormone
may cross your entire body it gets
dumped into the blood transmitted around
and it also has um a kind of generality
to it so to the extent that
you're being frightened
should
turn down certain systems that are not
priorities and turn up other systems you
can dump the frightened hormone into the
blood and it can trigger all the things
in the direction that they should go
right because they can just all have the
receptor and they know whether that
receptor is a hey time to wake up and
get moving or time to sideline this
activity and prioritize other things
message but sometimes that signal comes
after the frightening impetus and
sometimes it
is it seems to precede awareness
conscious awareness by the organism at
least right and yeah of course there's
an interplay of these things right what
what particular reaction you have may be
the overlap of you know several
different signals that tell you oh this
is that kind of event right this is a
this is a fear
this is an anticipatory fear rather than
oh crap i've got to flee that
frightening creature kind of a scenario
right um
but anyway the basic point is at some
level you're looking when we look at
hormones hormones are easy for us to
look at because it's a molecule and it's
either present or it isn't present or
it's present at some concentration that
goes up or down and so we can just
measure them and we can also
experimentally easily alter them right
you can just add some to the system and
see what it does
so they are
it's a very tractable set of systems and
as a result we know a lot about what it
does but we don't
necessarily have the logic nailed down
it's effectively like the ability to you
know
activate a circuit right if you had a
machine that you didn't understand right
and you you know took some piece of it
and you electrified that piece and you
know you watched that you know some
lever
does that right it's not that you know
the thing that you triggered the the
wire that you energized is about that
thing necessarily the point is that's
the lever is downstream
of the thing that you activated and you
may have activated a bunch of other
things and you could have gone farther
downstream and so
anyway this all lines up with a
um
it is sufficient but not necessary if i
activate something upstream and it
activates 20 things downstream but if i
had gone another step downstream it only
would have activated four then the point
is sufficient but not necessary because
you can go downstream and do the other
thing
so anyway i guess
i guess the point is complex systems are
tough
but the throw up your hands in response
to them
is not the right thing to do because
basically there's a logic they have to
be built out of a kind of logic that
with work can be unpacked yes and uh our
attempts to reduce to make linear
because it's easier to file in our own
heads our understanding of systems like
this well if a then b
you know the logic of
computer gates
uh
sometimes would appear to be the logic
of say synapses
uh but that does not mean that it's the
logic of say
uh
biofeedback and endocrinological systems
right that you have basically those
sorts of simple
you know and or not gates uh at one
level but that you have so many of those
systems laid on top of one another some
of which are themselves not using such
simple gates they are for instance um
not binary but actually gradated you
know qualitative responses rather than
quantitative responses you end up with
complexity uh that
cannot necessarily be perfectly
understood with a simple linear model
right and part of that you know you
point to the the discrete versus the
continuous and
neurons make a great case for this
because
in fact in each neuron it's both you've
got the the axon end which is discrete
it either fires the messenger it doesn't
and you've got the cell body which has
all of these dendritic inputs and there
are so many inputs and they you either
um you know get enough inputs short
enough packed in time and uh closely
enough together that you go above a
threshold and then the axon sends its
message or you don't so basically you
know the one message sent or not
binary but within
you know with within the cell body or no
i guess the axonal end and it's been a
while since i've done this but you know
you you have to hit some limit um before
the action potential actually in the
cell body and so and the thing is
it does make this point about you know
is the is the universe discrete or
continuous you know right and the answer
is yes the answer the answer is yes you
get enough discrete inputs and it
becomes effectively continuous
um
anyway i don't know whether that just
lost everybody but
but the the idea that yes these systems
i mean if you have enough you know logic
gates you can model the behavior of a
continuous system right you have to sort
of overwhelm the amount of actual
complexity in the system with
with these on off kind of
uh bits but
um
but anyway yes
there have to be simple rules otherwise
it would be impossible to get a complex
creature
of the sort that we are
[Music]